bonsoir à tous l'air du temps
alors comment sont
ont l'air heureux époque marquée par un
nouvel ordre des choses lorsqu'on entend
cette définition
on pense bien évidemment un changement
on pense à transformation et quels
changements le monde d'aujourd'hui est
résolument différent du monde d'hier et
le monde de demain le sera d'autant plus
différents et il faut pas aller très
loin pour s'en apercevoir il suffit
juste d'observer autour de nous vous ne
communiquez plus comme avant avec tous
les nouveaux moyens de communication
vous n'achetez plus comme avant avant
lorsque avant lorsque je voulais acheter
mon réfrigérateur donc gérer en magasin
et je me faisais conseillé par un
conseiller qui m'aidait justement parmi
les choix proposés aujourd'hui lorsque
j'arrive en point de vente je sais
exactement quel produit je veux acheter
et pour cause j'ai eu le monde entier
comme conseiller une fois un directeur
général madi qc morgan avant comme on
produit avait un problème aux etats unis
c'est pas grave parce qu'il cartonnait
en europe
aujourd'hui si un problème quelque part
sur la planète ça me plombe tout mes
ventes et de la même manière on ne se
déplace plus comme avant avec les
trottinettes les vélos les voitures en
libre service
le simple fait d'aller prendre un verre
avec vos amis vous le faites plus comme
avant vous choisissez avec google
whatsapp et maps prennent ensuite le
relais et il ya de nouveaux types de
mouvements ce que j'appelle les
mouvements 4.0 qui n'existait pas avant
ça a commencé avec les printemps arabes
ou des populations renverser le
gouvernement avec une arme fatale qui
s'appelle facebook
plus récemment il ya eu les gilet jaune
qui ne correspondent pas du tout aux
codes de manifestations qu'on a connue
en france jusqu'à présent la campagne
présidentielle d'emmanuel macron est
résolument différente de toutes les
autres campagnes qu'on a connue en
france le monde change profondément et
lorsqu'on pense à ces changements
la première chose qui nous vient la tête
c'est celle avancée technologique ce que
j'avais la quatrième révolution
industrielle ou par abus de langage le
digital alors qu'est ce que ça veut dire
quand on pense à quatrième révolution
industrielle on se dit ah oui il ya les
robots qui arrive
oui les robots qui viennent petit à
petit cohabiter avec nous et qui petit à
petit vont nous remplacer dans nos jobs
on parle de la de l'intelligence
artificielle qui a la capacité
aujourd'hui de traiter des quantités de
données justes exponentielle et qui en
plus la capacité de prédire je suis
capable d'identifier ce qu'un
consommateur est susceptible d'acheter
dans un mois et bien évidemment ça
arrive aussi avec ses nouveaux modèles
le modèle en libre service par exemple
mais surtout le modèle économique de la
donner
la data qui devient le nouvel eldorado
le nouveau nerf de la guerre des
entreprises et pour cause 90% des
données qui existe aujourd'hui sur notre
planète ont été créés sur les douze
derniers mois cette statistique
elle sera valable dans deux ans le monde
change et voilà ce à quoi on pense quand
on parle de quatrième révolution
industrielle
en réalité la définissent ce que je
viens de vous citer n'est qu'une partie
la définition la définition est un peu
plus complexe
si je devais vous donner la définition
complète ce serait de vous dire c'est
l'avancée des technologies qui fusionne
avec les sphères physique numérique et
biologiques et qui lève toutes les
barrières des grands modèles physiques
économiques sociétales environnementales
en fait si vous imaginez le monde comme
étant un diamant avec chacune des
facettes de ce diamant représentant un
grand modèle va vous me direz le monde
jusqu'à présent c'est toujours
transformé donc chacune des facettes du
diamant a évolué à sa manière à son
rythme
il ya quelques années quand y avait
encore des chevaux dans les villes va y
avait des points d'eau puis sont arrivés
les voitures et les points d'eau ont été
peu à peu remplacé par les stations
service saas et de la transformation la
quatrième révolution industrielle là on
est sûr de la mutation c'est à dire que
c'est pas une ou plusieurs facettes qui
mute
c'est le coeur même du diamant qui se
transforme complètement et qui impacte
des facs tôt l'intégralité des facettes
de manière simultanée et
interdépendantes
chacune des facettes deviennent liés
j'étais au cs le cône summer electronic
show qui a eu lieu début janvier qui
présente les dernières innovations qui
vont être présentés sur le marché et
donc d'un point de vue technologique les
technologies sont là en fait elle
fonctionne la vraie question dans 90%
des cas surtout les gens que j'ai
rencontrés c'était comment est ce que je
fais pour lancer nos produits
si on prend la voiture autonome mais
n'allons pas jusque là la voiture semi
autonome c'est à dire que j'ai encore un
conducteur et je dois avoir les mains
sur le volant bas pour pouvoir
commercialiser ce produit il faut que je
puisse travailler avec les constructeurs
de route il faut que je puisse
travailler que les autres constructeurs
automobiles parce qu'elles communiquent
entre elles faut que je puisse
travailler avec les gouvernements avec
les communes avec les banques avec les
assurances avec chacune des facettes
tout devient complètement lié et
interdépendants et si la voiture ne vous
parle pas on prend la pauvre trottinette
qui pose aujourd'hui un problème de vide
juridique
alors que la trottinette a toujours
existé le monde change
d'un point de vue philosophique michel
serres rappel cette transformation
cette révolution la troisième révolution
anthropologique majeur de l'histoire
après l'écriture et l'imprimerie voilà
qu'arrive le digital dans le sens où il
change complètement nos codes dans le
sens où un nouvel ordre se met en place
dans le sens où le noyau du diamant est
en train de muter
voilà ce que c'est la quatrième
révolution industrielle
alors maintenant forcément l'arrivée
quelques petites caractéristiques crois
pas tout les voir en revanche et des
caractéristiques qui sont plutôt
marquantes éloquente
la première caractéristique qu'on a
identifié c'est l'accélération du temps
le temps va beaucoup plus vite sur
chacune des facettes du diamant d'un
point de vue technologique des exemples
36 ans entre la création du premier
poste de radio et sa diffusion à 50000
utilisateurs quatre ans internet
aujourd'hui amazon est capable de mettre
de faire une évolution sur son site
internet toutes les secondes
aujourd'hui si je vais faire mes courses
en ligne je suis capable de livrer en
une heure
il ya moins de cinq ans je voulais
ouvrir un compte bancaire il fallait un
rendez-vous physique en banque et deux
semaines entre l'ouverte entre entre le
rendez-vous et l'ouverture effective du
compte aujourd'hui suis capable de le
faire en deux minutes sans même sortir
de chez moi
d'un point de vue sociologique il ya
l'écart entre les différentes
générations qui devient de plus en plus
courts on a un président qui a été élu à
39 ans soit 15 ans de moins que la
moyenne d'âge des présidents et c'est
pas un cas isolé dans le monde
aujourd'hui
le temps va beaucoup plus vite et par
effet de lui à l'it et l'espérance de
vie augmente donc on a encore plus de
temps de faire les choses encore plus
vite
et demain on aura encore plus de temps
de faire les choses encore plus
rapidement avec le transhumanisme le
temps s'accélère et s'accélère de plus
en plus et pourtant j'arrive à un stade
de ma vie ou pour moi le temps s'arrête
mon job c'est de comprendre ces
différents phénomènes que je suis en
train de vous exposer et accompagner les
entreprises dans leurs transformations
pour prendre en compte ces nouvelles
problématiques qui deviennent crucial si
elle ne se transforme pas elles ne
survivent pas j'en suis convaincu je le
sais le monde change le temps s'accélère
il faut se transformer le monde change
le temps s'accélère il faut se
transformer le monde change le temps
s'accélère il faut se transformer
j'adore ça et puis survient le doute est
ce que je suis dans la bonne direction
face à un nouveau phénomène qui
finalement est incertain est-ce que j'ai
vraiment un impact positif en faisant ce
que je fais quel est le sens de ce que
je fais c'est la vraie question est
du coup comme toute personne n'essaye
pas forcément d'éviter le problème mais
d'aller voir ailleurs ce qui se passe de
m'intéresser à autre chose là où je
pourrais potentiellement avoir un impact
positif et forcément je m'intéresse aux
problématiques environnementales l'air à
hier
je pense que l'actualité
enfin vous êtes tous au courant de
l'actualité il ya des incendies en
australie
les stations de neige sans neige sans
mauvais jeu de mots il ya une grosse
problématique environnementale
aujourd'hui la planète est en danger il
y avait le world economic forum qui
avait lieu fin janvier qui réunit tous
les grands dirigeants du monde pour
définir quelles sont les priorités de
l'année 2020 sur les cinq priorités
définies trois d'entre elles sont
environnementale et pour cause
83% de la flore marines a été détruite
par les industries or les industries ont
besoin
cette flore marines pour pouvoir
fonctionner donc par effet de
schématisation sylla l'industrie n'est
pas capable de répondre à la halle à la
demande
alors pas de croissance si pas de
croissance alors pas d'économistes et
pas d'économie alors c'est la crise qui
dit crise dit chômage et dans ce cas
précis même les robots seraient au
chômage
le monde change et donc j'étais en train
de creuser et ya quelque chose qui m'a
sauté aux yeux
ce sujet environnemental est un sujet
global globalisation deuxième
caractéristique de la quatrième
révolution industrielle
en fait plus j'ai essayé de m'éloigner
du sujet plus le sujet me rattraper
globalisation réflexion globale et non
pas mondialisation parce qu'on est on
est sur l' inverse en fait la
mondialisation c'est lorsqu'on a un
concept et qu'on ne décline partout dans
le monde avec potentiellement quelques
adaptations
la subtilité avec la globalisation c'est
pour pouvoir répondre à une
problématique globale il faut pouvoir
agir au niveau le plus local au niveau
du diamant de chaque individu et c'est
comme ça qu'on arrivera à répondre à la
problématique globale de l'environnement
c'est comme ça que sont réapparus les
circuits courts c'est comme ça qui est
apparue l'économie circulaire
et comme ça qu'on est en train de
défaire tout ce qu'on a fait sur les
dernières années autrement dit on
relocalise ce qu on a délocalisé
globalisation et ça commençait à prendre
petit à petit sens du coup dans le
silence et dans les doutes que j'avais
en fait je pars avec des directions
marketing tous les jours et dans des
fûts sur des sujets justement globaux
les points du marketing c'est la
personnalisation voir l'hyper
personnalisation quelle belle dualité de
la même manière les sociétés les plus
globalisées aujourd'hui sont les gaffes
à google amazon facebook apple
aujourd'hui ces sociétés sont les plus
globalisées et pourtant c'est les
sociétés qui sont capables de cibler une
personne spécifique c'est-à-dire que
pour pouvoir être globale il faut
pouvoir être au plus fin de la
localisation réflexion globale vision
locale
c'est la vision des gaffes à gaza qui
d'ailleurs a aujourd'hui beaucoup plus
d'informations sur un individu que son
propre gouvernement
l'air ailleurs le gouvernement la
facette du gouvernement doit également
se transformer elle doit passer d'un
état réactif à un état proactif face aux
gaffes a par exemple si à l'échelle de
l'europe
on a tendance à vouloir mettre en place
des réglementations alors ok très bien
l'objectif et bienveillance et de
protéger la population
la problématique c'est qu'un google et
un facebook auront les moyens humains et
financiers de pouvoir appliquer cette
réglementation mais la petite start up
française elle qui déjà remet doit
rattraper le retard pour attraper les
gaffes à face à un temps qui s'accélère
de plus en plus doit en plus se prendre
dans la figure une nouvelle
réglementation donc c'est le serpent qui
se mord la queue en fait ça veut dire
que la mutation du gouvernement est
obligatoire dans ce nouveau contexte on
doit passer d'un état réactif un état
proactif ou la proactivité et la
définition d'un espace de droit qui a
été réfléchie globalement avec tous les
autres gouvernements pour pouvoir
laisser la même chance à tout le monde
et il faut bien évidemment face à une
problématique environnementale qui
devient de plus en plus forte
mettre de côté d'un point de vue
gouvernemental les problématiques qui
sont purement local pour réfléchir
global parce que quand on sait que la
planète est peut- on va te
potentiellement disparaître dans
quelques années avec tout ce qui se
passe est ce qu'on est vraiment en train
de se poser la question savoir s'il
existe ou pas fondamentalement j'aurais
pas prioriser les choses de la même
manière et je commençais dans mon
silence dans le doute que j'avais à
réellement comprendre
en fait cette quatrième révolution
industrielle
si elle n'était pas arrivée on n'aurait
pas pu identifier aussi rapidement la
problématique environnementale et de la
même manière pour pouvoir répondre aux
problématiques que je viens de vous
citer on a besoin de cette quatrième
révolution industrielle doivent être
s'était pas que j'avais perdu le sens
c'est que face à tout ce qui se passe
bah on maîtrise pas forcément on sait
pas ce qui va arriver et donc forcément
on résiste au changement
on se raccroche à ce qu'on connaît et
sait ce qui m'était arrivé et c'est ce
qui a créé le doute
pour moi c'est à dire que je prône le
changement tous les jours auprès des
entreprises pour l'heure il faut se
transformer le montrent le temps
s'accélère et en fait quand le
changement m'est arrivé j'ai juste pas
eu la lucidité de m'en rendre compte
et une fois qu'on a compris ça et qu'on
décide d'embrasser ce changement de
prendre un point de vue positif et en
fait on se rend compte que c'est juste
up
en fait si je ramène ça à la quatrième
révolution industrielle
oui demain les robots vont nous
remplacer c'est un fait
et vous savez quoi ils sont encore plus
productif que nous qu'est ce que ça veut
dire
soit on se dit bas ok très bien c'est
une et luc table qu'est ce que je fais
et je vais dans le négatif soit je vais
plutôt sur du positif et le positif
c'est quoi c'est qu'aujourd'hui tout ce
que vous avez de l'ordre du loisir sont
des choses qui ne sont pas robotisée à
bhl et donc du coup qui vont être
revalorisées et je me dis mais ça va
être super de pouvoir faire de la
peinture de la lecture du sport toute
activité créative
parce qu'elle va être reconnu encore
plus qu'aujourd'hui puisque les robots
prendront tout leur est finalement
et j'en vois déjà qui disent oui mais
alors les robots vont pas tous remplacés
alors il ya une enquête d'harvard
business review qui est sorti a pas très
longtemps je vous rassure tout le monde
est impactée toute la pyramide de
qualification est impactée même les
métiers les plus qualifiés comme la
médecine est un métier qui va évoluer et
qui va être robotisée qu'on l'admette
aujourd'hui ou pas et puis de la même
manière oui il va y avoir des
suppressions d'emplois c'est un fait
et puis des 1 ce qui n'est pas forcément
tout à fait vrai puisque les
statistiques sur les prochaines années
montre kim avoir 350 mille emplois en
plus pour être totalement prêts si va
voir 650 mille emplois en moins et avoir
un million de jobs en plus petite
spécificité 90% des jobs qui vont
exister ici cinq ans n'existe pas
aujourd'hui qu'est ce que ça veut dire
ça veut dire que le mouton à cinq pattes
n'existe pas puisque personne n'aura
assez de recul pour pouvoir dire oui en
fait j'ai besoin de tels profils puisque
le profil n'existe 20 le métier sera
nouveau et donc ça c'est juste
extraordinaire parce que ça rabat
totalement les cartes du marché de
l'emploi et des gens qui n'ont
aujourd'hui pas accès à l'emploi
pourront demain accéder et se former
plus facilement ce qui signifie par
ailleurs que le sait c'est que le
système éducatif même devra être revu
puisque est-ce qu'on peut enseigner une
spécialité à air sur un métier qu'on ne
connaît pas telle est la question
l'interdépendance des diamants du
diamant c'est ce que je vous disais tout
à l'heure
le monde change et j'avais enfin compris
en fait le silence a réveillé la passion
et je me suis dit ok j'ai compris je
fais mon travail parce que j'ai
l'opportunité tous les jours de pouvoir
apporter ma pierre à l'édifice d'aider
les entreprises à comprendre ces
phénomènes à se transformer pour pouvoir
répondre aux nouvelles problématiques du
monde
finalement à mon humble niveau et
surtout de pouvoir les aider à se
transformer pour protéger la planète
j'avais trouvé mon sens et ça c'est
quelque chose qu'on peut tous faire en
fait parce qu'on est sur un alignement
des planètes où toutes les cartes sont
rabattus donc en fait que vous soyez
parent enfant entrepreneurs que vous
soyez plombier pompiers quel que soit ce
que vous faites même si vous
une rock star vous avez tous
l'opportunité d'apporter votre pierre à
l'édifice vous avez tous l'opportunité
de travailler pour protéger la planète
ou sur une des facettes qui de toute
façon convergera puisque comme je vous
le disais le sont convergentes élevé
l'humanité vers une nouvelle conscience
c'est la beauté et la conclusion de mon
ted merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]